[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild hallo liebe Leute heute schauen wir
in so abgrundtiefe Kälte und
Bösartigkeit das es einen erschüttert um
den Fall besser zu verstehen müssen wir
in den Irak des Jahres 2014 zurückgehen
als der sogenannte islamische Staat im
Irak und Syrien also kurz Isis ein
großes Gebiet beherrschte und tausende
Menschen tötete das sincha Gebirge seit
August letzte Zuflucht der Jesiden vor
den mordenden Kommandos des islamischen
Staates der Einsatz der peschmerger
Kämpfer zur Rettung der Jesiden ist eine
brandgefährliche Operation die
Hubschrauber werden so oft angegriffen
dass nach der Landung alles extrem
schnell gehen muss die Kämpfer springen
auf die Erde und dann stürmen die
Menschen auch schon
hinein
das Grauen über das wir heute reden
begann in der Nacht vom 2 auf den 3
August 2014 mit der Invasion des
sogenannten islamischen Staates das
erklärte Ziel der isterroristen wir
haben es gehört war die systematische
Auslöschung der ISIN Frauen Töchter und
Kinder mussten damals mit ansehen die
es-kämpfer in die Dörfer eindrangen und
ihre Männer Väter und Brüder ermordeten
ganze Dorfbevölkerung wurden verschleppt
und auch für immer auseinander gerissen
junge Frauen und Mädchen wurden
vergewaltigt und als Sklavinnen
verschleppt und in unmenschlicher Weise
verkauft das war eine Reportage aus dem
sinchar Gebirge und die
Bundestagsabgeordnete derja Türk
Nachbauer von der SPD wir erzählen aus
dieser Schreckenszeit heute eine
Geschichte die für die ganze
Verkommenheit dieser selbsternannten
gotteskämpfer steht ich bin Stefan
etzeband und ich bin Mirko Kasimir hallo
schön dass ihr dabei seid den heutigen
Fall hat unsere Reporterin Lena Zander
für Bild begleitet und sie beginnt mit
der Hauptperson mit einer scheinbar ganz
normalen jungen Frau aus Norddeutschland
ja Jennifer W das war ein junges Mädchen
aus einer Kleinstadt in Niedersachsen
die hat sich
2014 dem islamischen Staat angeschlossen
ist von lone nach fallutscher gezogen
hat dort einen is-kämpfer geheiratet und
die beiden haben sich einer Sklavin
gehalten man muss sich das so vorstellen
die Jesiden waren eine Minderheit die
wurden versklavt gefoltert die Männer
wurden zum größten Teil getötet und die
Frauen wie Vieh auf einem Sklavenmarkt
angeboten mit ihren Kindern zusammen
Jennifer W und ihr Mann hatten sich eine
solche Sklavin gehalten wir nennen sie
einfach Bahira Bahira hatte eine
fünfjährige Tochter das ist bis heute
schwer zu verstehen finde ich da sind
junge Frauen aus der Mitte der deutschen
Gesellschaft manche vielleicht auch aus
ein bisschen schwierigen Verhältnissen
und die gehen nach Syrien oder in den
Irak zu Typen die wie besessene
schlechter wüten und ihren Frauen aus
angeblich religiösen Gründen fast alles
verbieten aber es ist tausendfach
passiert das böse Erwachen kam meist
später der Fall von Jennifer W schärft
da vielleicht ein bisschen die Sicht auf
die Motive denn sie und ihr Mann haben
durch diesen Islam stat plötzlich sowas
wie macht sie können Ihre jesidische
Sklavin anbrüllen und herumschupsen und
sich dabei selbstgoß und wichtig fühlen
was als Machtgefühl begonnen hat wurde
dann vielleicht Sadismus und schließlich
eine Form der Unmenschlichkeit die ich
tut mir leid aber die ich nur als die
von Monstern bezeichnen kann
bildreporterin Lena Sander im September
2015 wurde das kleine Mädchen krank das
heißt die hat wie Kinder das in dem
Alter tun sich eingenäst auf einer
Matratze und der Mann von Jennifer wurde
so wütend dass er das Mädchen aus dem
Haus schleifte es bei säen der Hitze es
waren über 40° draußen ankettete und
Jennifer W sah tatenlos zu wie dieses
kleine Mädchen in der Hitze
verdurstete was besonders perfide ist
Jennifer WE ist selbst Mutter das
Mädchen hat hat geweint als es krank war
und ins Bett gemacht als sein Peiniger
der Mann von Jennifer W es anschrie und
bedrohte und Bahira muss mit anhören wie
ihre 5 Jahre alte Tochter die gerade
einen Infekt hat draußen verdurstet und
einen Hitzekollaps erleidet Jennifer WS
Mann hat das Mädchen mit einem
Elektrokabel so an ein Fenster gebunden
dass es mit dem Gesicht zur Sonne an dem
Gitter hängt ohne mit den Füßen den
Boden berühren und sich abstützen zu
können das Mädchen ruft stundenlang
verzweifelt nach seiner Mama Bahira
antwortet sie könne ihr nicht helfen da
sie so große Angst vor Jennifers Mann
habe schließlich verstummt das Kind
Jennifer so beteuert sie es später im
ersten Prozess habe von all dem zunächst
gar nichts mitbekommen als sie das Kind
im Hof entdeckte da habe sie ihrem Mann
gesagt das Mädchen würde doch bald
sterben der habe erst gesagt das sei
doch okay dann habe er aber doch das
Kind abgebunden und sei mit ihm ins
Krankenhaus gefahren dort sei das
Mädchen schließlich gestorben als pahira
in den folgenden Tagen um ihre Tochter
weint hät Jenifer ihr eine Waffe an den
Kopf und droht sie zu erschießen die
folgenden Jahre und Ereignisse sind sehr
chaotisch und werden in den Wirren der
isish Herrschaft nur zum kleinsten Teil
aktenkundig was wir zusammengetragen
haben geht in etwa so Jennifer und ihr
Mann fliehen bald nach dem Tod des
Mädchens vom irakischen fallua in die
Türkei weil ihm wegen der tödlichen
Kindesmisshandlung selbst im islamischen
Staat eine Haft droht in der Türkei wird
Jennifer wieder schwanger und reist
zurück in ihre deutsche Heimat nach lone
in Niedersachsen dort bekommt sie das
Kind Bahira unterdessen kann sich aus
den Fängen der Isis befreien und landet
im Nordirak in einem Flüchtlingslager
der Kurden dort kann sie ihre Geschichte
einer Mitarbeiterin der
Hilfsorganisation yasda erzählen und so
werden Ihre ig die Mörder ihrer Tochter
schon bald international gesucht das
bedeutet aber nicht dass ihr Verhältnis
zum islamischen Staat sich geändert hat
zwei weitere Jahre später will sie mit
dem Kind zurück nach fallua in den Irak
die Umstände könnten auch aus einem
Agenten Thriller sein im Mai 2018 nimmt
Jennifer W über das Internet wieder
Kontakt zu gewehrsleuten der terrormiliz
auf also Isis aber die CIA hört mit der
us en im September macht sie sich mit
ihrer Tochter im Auto in Richtung Türkei
auf den Weg ihr Fahrer aber ist ein
Agent das Auto ist verwanzt und an einer
Raststätte wird sie schließlich
festgenommen es tritt also ein was man
während der grauensherrschaft des is
kaum zu hoffen wagte Einzelfälle des
Völkermordes an den Jesiden werden vor
Gericht
aufgearbeitet eine große Rolle hat auch
bei dem Fall amal Kuni gespielt Amali
ist die Ehefrau von George cloney dem
Hollywood Schauspieler und sie ist eine
begnadete
Menschenrechtsanwältin und hat sich
immer sehr für solche Fälle eingesetzt
und deswegen ist dieser Fall auch so
ganz besonders es ist der erste Fall
weltweit gewesen der Jesiden ein Forum
gegeben hat der jemanden vor Gericht
gestellt hat und gesagt hat das was ihr
getan habt ist ein Verbrechen gegen die
Menschlichkeit wir klagendes an und
Jennifer W wurde in Bayern gefasst sie
war gerade in Deutschland zu zu Besuch
und deswegen fand dieser Prozess auch in
München statt für diesen ersten Prozess
im Jahr
2021 kommt auch Bahira nach Deutschland
aber die Umstände kann man nur
unvollständig erzählen die war für den
Prozess in Deutschland wo genau sie
gelebt hat das wurde aus
Sicherheitsgründen nicht bekannt gegeben
sie war vor Ort sie hat auch vor Gericht
ausgesagt das ganze gestaltete sich
wahnsinnig schwierig weil sie auch eine
Dolmetscherin hatte die nicht ganz
verstanden hatte was sie da eigentlich
sagt es ist wahnsinnig schwierig eine
Dolmetscherin ein Dolmetscher zu finden
der überhaupt diese Sprache spricht weil
das ja mit Dialekten und alles sehr
unterschiedlich ist deswegen gestaltete
sich die Aussage der Mutter schwierig es
war wahnsinnig C zwischendurch wurde
dann auch der dolmcher gewechselt und
dann ging das ganze auch besser der
Prozess wird in der Öffentlichkeit sehr
aufmerksam verfolgt die
Horrorgeschichten aus dem Irak die
rätselhaften freiwilligen Gefolgsleute
aus Deutschland bekommen endlich ein
Gesicht die große Frage war für uns vor
erstmal kommt Jennifer W verschleiert
trägt sie eine Burker oder wie tritt sie
überhaupt auf sie kam letztendlich in
einer weißen Bluse mit einem schwarzen
Blazer die langen schwarzen Haare
zurückgebunden das Gesicht fah eine
kleine zierliche Frau die auch kein
großes Aufsehen erregt hat das Gericht
verurteilt Jennifer W zu einer
gesamtfreiheitsstra von 10 Jahren unter
anderem wegen Beihilfe zum versuchten
Mord durch Unterlassen Mitgliedschaft in
einer terroristischen Vereinigung im
Ausland sowie wegen eines Verbrechens
gegen die Menschlichkeit mit Todesfolge
die Bundesanwaltschaft hatte eine
lebenslange Freiheitsstrafe wegen Mordes
gefordert aber das Gericht machte
geltend dass man nicht sicher wisse ob
das Kind noch zu retten gewesen sei und
folgte hier dem Grundsatz im Zweifel für
die Angeklagte als strafmelder wertet
das Gericht dass we nicht die treibende
Kraft bei der Tötung des Kindes gewesen
sei zudem habe sie zwar eine
Haushaltshilfe gefordert ihr sei jedoch
keine Aufforderung zum sklavenkauf
nachzuweisen daran sei sie auch nicht
beteiligt gewesen wenngleich sie die
Aufsicht über die jesidinnen übernommen
hatte verantworten muss we sich aber für
die mitausnutzung der von ihrem Mann
geschaffenen Zwangslage der Sklavinnen
im ersten Prozess sie hat die meiste
Zeit dort gesessen und eigentlich
schwiegen als ihr dann das letzte Wort
erteilt wurde sagte sie sinngemäß an ihr
solle jetzt ein Exempel statuiert werden
also von Reue war dort nicht zu spüren
sie wurde dann ja auch zu 10 Jahren Haft
verurteilt doch das ganze ging dann zum
Bundesgerichtshof und der Fall wurde
noch mal neu aufgerollt und jetzt im
August diesen Jahres ist das zweite
Urteil das endgültige Urteil gefallen
und dort hat sie dann 14 Jahre Haft
bekommen und hat während des Prozesses
auch ausgesagt und dort hat sie sich
auch entschuldigt unter Tränen auch Reue
gezeigt wie glaubwürdig das ist dass sei
dahingestellt doch da hat sie sich dann
auch zum ersten mal geäußert und sich
auch
entschuldigt so hat Bahira am Ende
Gerechtigkeit erfahren für den Tod ihrer
Tochter wie es ihr damit ging das wissen
wir leider nicht alles was sich um
Bahira dreht unterliegt strengen
Sicherheitsvorkehrung des we en sie war
zu der Zeit des Prozesses in Deutschland
sie war auch definitiv bei der ersten
Urteilsverkündung mit dabei aber ganz
klar wird diese Frauen natürlich
beschützt und da wird auch ihr
Aufenthaltsort geheim gehalten
bildreporterin Lena Zander wird dieses
Schicksal auf jeden Fall nie vergessen
was mir besonders haften geblieben ist
ist der Ausdruck von Jennifer W ein
solches Verbrechen es geht hier um
Verbrechen gegen die Menschlichkeit es
geht hier um ein Terror Regime es geht
um ein fünfjähriges Mädchen das
verdurstet während man selbst auch noch
Mutter ist was ich finde was es noch mal
schlimmer macht obwohl die Tat schon
schlimm ist und dort zu sitzen sich kaum
zu regen sich erst so viel später also 8
Jahre nachdem das Mädchen gestorben ist
auch zu entschuldigen das finde ich
wirklich wahnsinnig schlimm diese Kälte
die sie ausgestrahlt hat zwischendurch
ja wie ist die Lage der jesidischen
Minderheit heute das hat der Tage
Spiegel gerade in diesem August goda
alkaidi gefragt er ist kovorsitzender
des Vereins Stelle für jesidische
Angelegenheiten und
Islamwissenschaftler seine Antwort
leider ist die Lage der Jesiden bis
heute sehr schwierig schätzungsweise
500.000 wurden in den vergangenen Jahren
aus ihrer Heimat in der nordirakischen
Region sincha vertrieben obwohl der
islamische Staat vor mehr als vier
Jahren militärisch besiegt und sincha
befreit wurde durften bislang kaum mehr
als 70 000 Menschen
zurückkehren zudem wird seit Monaten
massiv gegen die Minderheit gehetzt und
zwar von kurdisch sonitischen
mullas das war Tatort Deutschland für
heute danke fürs Zuhören euer Stefan und
euer Mirko bis zum nächsten
Mal